los derechos humanos no pueden ser
instrumentalizados politizados ni
tratados con doble rasero lo ha dicho el
presidente chino xi jinping a michelle
bachelet la alta comisionada en
videoconferencia durante su viaje a
china para investigar la situación de
los uigures está según la versión del
ministerio de exteriores chino habría
mostrado su admiración por los logros y
esfuerzos de china en la protección de
los derechos humanos la conversación ha
servido para que se desgrane su visión
sobre los derechos humanos le ha dicho
que cada país tiene que encontrar su
senda y que la exportación ciega de un
modelo universal sólo consigue traer
desastres que acaba pagando el pueblo es
un argumento que la prensa nacional
suele acompañar de los ejemplos de las
campañas de eeuu en irak y afganistán
también ha dicho sí que la prioridad en
el mundo en desarrollo es la
subsistencia a la mejora de las
condiciones de vida y recordar los
cientos de millones de personas que
china ha sacado de la pobreza en las
últimas décadas una diferencia
sustancial entre la teoría de los
derechos humanos en europa y en china es
que en la primera
de la revolución francesa y se acentúa
al individuo mientras que la cultura
confuciana pone su énfasis en la
sociedad y eso explica que muchos aquí
vean aquella concepción como egoísta